[Music]
Garth Brooks tells you like it is and
his new anthology you learn so much
about the superstars career and his
personal life to his wife of nearly 12
years Trisha Yearwood actually wrote a
letter to guard this on the back cover
and in part two of my exclusive there is
one word she uses that still gets to car
I'm proud of you husband and it's proud
to be a part of the Garth Brooks
phenomenon and call me husband aha when
I read Garth what Tricia wrote to him he
just couldn't hold back those tears and
you get more handsome with each year
that passes true story I love you sweet
is that the line to get you I just she
calls me husband that's the line me
that's what I get you that's a lucky man
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the very first photos from the
time Garth and Trisha first met is
included in the anthology part one in
the first five years and you gotta love
how he wears his heart on the sleeve one
of the great things about you is that
you are very emotional and you will cry
very easily unabashedly we like that in
a man well I don't know I don't like it
in a guy so it's a little better I love
it
you know what if whatever Trisha liked
me dressing up like a poodle I would do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and of course fans will do anything for
him fact gourville finishes three ear
tour in Nashville and more than 100,000
tickets have been sold in that city
alone he's quite popular can I get a
ticket yes
[Music]
you